in order to help you segue into this
okay try and talk really fast you guys
are doing really well I'm falling so far
we know how to graph lots of things we
know how to graph straight lines I
alluded to that a little while ago we
now know how to graph parabolas they're
cold other shapes right that you also
realize that you also know how to graph
what other kinds of shapes do you know
how to graph on a Cartesian plane
any takers circles okay
there is one more which I'm just going
to leave off for a second which is
Exponential's and you'll see why I've
left it off in a minute this is you
quickly remember what like as equations
what these roughly looks like okay now
the equation of a line that'll be
something like y equals MX plus B seen
those before
travelers we just looked at those
circles what might be an example of the
equation of a circle I'll give you a
clue it'll start with an X usually okay
very very close I'm gonna put in a Y in
there to be wise in this somewhere to
make it an equation a circle anyway and
over here on the right hand side I'm
gonna put R squared it's R because in a
circle most important feature probably
is the radius thank you very much right
so for instance if I had x squared plus
y squared equals 25 okay that's going to
be a circle with its center at the
origin and its radius is going to be
where 25 is 5 squared right so the
radius would be just five radius is it
25 it's five squared okay so that's a
circle what's hyper like the equation I
mean oh yeah okay that's that's one way
of writing it a more common way of
writing at least what we've seen in this
course looks like this y equals 100
okay now here's the reason why I've
picked out these four okay when we try
and find out where these collide with
each other
okay the pictures that you get a kind of
interesting and on the right hand side
here I'd like you to draw a few very
small pictures okay
so I've already got a promise I'm gonna
cheat a little bit and use that one draw
with me a simple circle and a simple
hyperbole I'll show you what they so
let's just draw a simple circle maybe
set a unit circle
okay I'm not actually as you'll see I'm
gonna need any markings for the numbers
and I hope like that looks like a
standard hyperbole like the one that
I've just written there has this kind of
wiener in shape I've got some dotted
lines on isn't or even what they called
starts with a name they are axes which
is crude metal and not what I meant
they also the dotted lines a means of
our asymptotes which is why they're
dotted what do I seem totes mean in this
case they are imaginary lines they don't
actually part of a graph but they do
tell us where the graph goes right I can
get closer and closer and closer to
asymptotes but can I actually get there
and same thing over here so for all of
these I could write them just like it
for a straight line I could write all of
them in all kinds of different formats
right we call them forms in fact so they
all give you different features which is
why you have them to point for real
yeah yes that's right it's a whole
variety is alright but the forms are not
so important what we're gonna we get at
the motor which is why I'm not
highlighting them okay I don't want even
confusing different positions okay now
I've got a probability of a circle day
I've got a hype over here what I'm
interested is where do these graphs
intersect if I put another straight line
on the
another straight line on the picture
let's start with that parabola review if
I put a straight line in like sadie's
he's a straight line I have no idea what
it's the question is but that doesn't
matter how many times does it intersect
806 times but you can see them there one
two okay I can draw a whole bunch of
life that intersect with it
twice I can also draw a line that
intersects with it once could you give
me an example could you describe
verbally where could I put a line so it
will just intersect once I can put one
through the vertex I can go bang
straight across right I could draw like
one vertically I'll just draw one like
this if that's very cool for sure it's
only ever gonna hit once more like you
said I can draw one command
okay I can also very easily draw a line
that never intersects with the parabola
right where could I draw one of those
yeah I could draw it underneath like
somewhere over here okay these guys are
never going to hit right two points one
point zero points can you draw a
straight line that hits at three points
is it possible you think about it you
can put a ruler on top of our parabola
that you run that you drew and you can
think okay where where can I possibly
move this thing can I come up with a
line any of these lines that hits three
times and as it happens if you're
drawing a straight line you can't okay
if you wanted to hit more times
it's tell you to wiggle around or curve
okay so being that I've got a maximum of
two points I can find these points of
intersection by using a quadratic okay
now just let's not surprising because
this parabola is a quadratic but I want
you to take that idea now and think
about these two shapes the circle and
the hyperbola okay I can draw a line
that intersects with my circle two times
Connor I've been just draw one like this
can you tell me where I could draw a
line that would intersect at the once
know you like it I could do why not like
across the bottom here it's called a
tangent and just as easily I can draw a
line bit
decisive the second alright let's put
this learner on for you okay can you
draw a line that intersects with the
circle three times no you can't unless
like I said it like we goes around and
curves okay
now you don't need me probably this is
predictable right when you look at this
hyperbola I can do this again can i
right I can draw a line like this it's
twice I can draw a line like this that's
twice as well I could try to my my back
which is once and I could draw a line
where do I draw a line so it doesn't get
down here okay well now it's tricky as
it happens because this shape is like
kind of like this one but inside out
right so actually outside is not where I
want to go I want to go inside I want to
go somewhere down the middle okay
because I've got this same arrangement
here just like here I can solve these
points of intersection in exactly the
same way now that's a little more
surprising right because this is not a
quadratic and neither is this but when I
solve them I will get a quadratic okay
so we just have enough time for us to
run through some really really brief
examples okay so would you please write
down let's try to depict would you write
down this pair of equations y equals x
plus 2 y equals x plus 2 and x squared
plus y squared equals 4 okay
now as it happens conveniently this
pretend circle for the drill just Rover
he drew it read them this is actually
not that bad a representation of x
squared plus y squared equals 4 remember
it's an R squared on the answer what's
the radius of this circle it's gonna be
2 is it's the square root of that number
okay so I'm gonna put it to he a 2 here
- two - two okay so I just do it when I
draw this line y equals x plus two to
the straight line okay what a straight
lines no play you can tell me because
you told me 20 minutes ago
what's the y-intercept of this line I'm
pointy and anti it's two it's just that
number okay so it's off
yeah doesn't take that much to work out
that the x intercept will be negative
two it'll be over here so here's the
line I want you can see it hits twice
where does it hit one of the coordinates
of those points we're gonna find him
okay
now he's the key ID to find points in
interception solve these two equations
right because they're happy at the same
time we call these you've met these
before starts with this things that
happened the same time simultaneously
you know much solve simultaneously solve
these two at the same time by
substitution is that enough answers for
you solve simultaneously by substitution
okay here's the way it works we take
this straight line y equals x prostitute
and I'm gonna start it 2x plus 2
everywhere I see Y in the second
equation
you cats that's my substitution step
okay so I'm going to my this x squared
plus instead of Y squared what should I
write X plus 2 squared right so there is
my substitution it was before I saw
stood no a song okay let's have a look
at this down here I've got x squared
plus can you expand that um factorize
turn there x squared + 4 X + equals 4
what happens how do I get that do you
them how I got that to get the 4x I
double this and multiply by that and
then to get this I square this as a
coincidence
went to when you double it it's the same
square it because it's too so now what I
do with this thing what kind of steps
could I take any suggestions I can what
would you like me to move to the other
side
no.4 okay so either for here for here
moving it to the other side would be
disappears from both of them right
because you're subtracting before I'm
going to therefore I look at writing
because it's disappeared right I'll get
zero right it's like what else can I do
I can click those like terms Connor I've
got two of them right so I'm going to
write 2x square
what's left over what's the time I've
done even with it's just for x2 just
hanging out there now what I can
factorize I will factorize in a second
but there's one thing I can do to make
it easier for me before I factorize I
can simplify this because can you see
all the numbers on the front those
coefficients there that's what we call
those numbers on the front they're all
even do you notice that so I can divide
all of them by two which leaves me with
this which is just marginally simpler
okay now I'm gonna factorize what can I
take out and take out next that leaves
me with X plus the tune of them okay I
factorize now like in solve x equals two
values what are they when I get from
this one it's just zero and what do I
get from this one careful I want I want
this to be zero or I want this to be
zero done this one to make this your
idea to negatives don't need too much
for that
okay now does that make sense yeah it
totally makes sense because these values
are the ones I was expecting right
there's x equals zero and there's x
equals negative two as a last step just
before you leave I found X values but
what do I need for a point a point when
has two values I need a wide
okay so I'm gonna say if x equals zero
let's chuck it back in here right for
this what is y equal to two if x equals
negative two chuck it back in here
what's y equal to negative one to zero
hey guys there's one of my points zero
two and here is the other point negative
2 to 0 okay we'll pick up the rest of it
on Tuesday